Speaker 1: I want to talk briefly about something
going on in Poland now. I've mentioned before
there are a number of epicenters
of nationalism of different kinds,
as well as anti-Semitism, which often go very much
together in Europe. Poland, sadly, is one of those
places, and I want to tell you about what's been
going on there. Death to Jews was being chanted
by Polish nationalists at a rally during which
they were burning books about Jews in Poland.
This is 20, 21 Polish nationalists shouted death
to Jews as they burned a book representing a
historic pact protecting the rights of Poland's
Jews. The book, burning at a rally in Collar's,
a city of about 100000 one hundred
and twenty miles southwest of Warsaw,
was part of a series of national nationalist
events. Last week, National Independence Day,
which is the anniversary of when Poland regained
sovereignty in 1918, videos and eyewitness
accounts on social media show a far right activist
whose name I'm not even going to try to pronounce
lit a red, red covered book meant to symbolize
the statue of Collis. The document, issued in 12
64 by Prince Balazs Law, the pious regulated the
legal status of Jews living in Poland and afforded
some protection through penalizing attacks on
them. The statue served as the legal foundation
for relations between non-Jews and Jews in Poland.
This guy poured a flammable liquid on the book and
lit it on fire. The crowd was chanting Death to
Jews. Some chanted, No to Poland. Yes to Poland.
Poland is both the Hebrew language name for Poland
and the name of the main Jewish museum in Warsaw.
Police are studying the footage, studying the
footage, and the EU Coordinator for Fighting
anti-Semitism, Katerina von Sherborne, wrote
on Twitter. These pictures send shivers down
the spine. Other large nationalist events also
taking place in Poland. You know, it's really
it's really sad to me what's going on in Poland,
as I think mentioned before my family. Jews from
Eastern Europe coming from really two main places
Ukraine on my dad's side and Poland and Romania
on my mom's side. My grandfather was actually born
in Poland, fled Poland when he was five in 1929 to
Argentina. And Poland is a place where the Jewish
population was quite literally decimated or more
through World War Two. And it is still a place
where there is disgusting hostility, open
hostility to Jews. There's this crazy story I may
have told before. A few years ago, when my dad had
a conference in Poland, he was walking around some
I forget what city it was in, but there were some
sort of notable homes in which I think it was
like Jews were hidden during the Holocaust or
something like that. You know, notable notable
places. And it's a place where tour groups go.
And there was a group of college students
doing a survey of folks who were there and
they said to my dad, Do you want? Can we can we
interview you for the survey? My dad says, sure.
And one of the questions is how much would you
be bothered if Jews moved in next door to you and
the options were a little bit a moderate amount, a
lot. And I would move out because it would bother
me so much. And my dad pointed out, you know, with
the language barrier to some degree that existed
there, everybody trying to speak English. Why
isn't that an option that I might not be bothered
at all, at all by Jews moving in next to me?
It's sort of a strange absence of an option,
and it sort of struck the interviewers as like,
Oh yeah, maybe, maybe that should be an option.
It didn't even occur to us that maybe that's
a reasonable option. So even like this is
an example of how this was not presumably an
overtly anti-Semitic study that was being done,
but the absence of I wouldn't be bothered
if Jews moved in next door was very strange.
And there's kind of this underlying thing that
that it's still there, entrenched in some way
in parts of Poland. So that's what's going
on in Poland. We've been covering the rise
of nationalism in Europe, in different countries
and very, very scary stuff. You can find me on
Twitter at De Packman. We're going to take
a quick break and be right back after this.